who sent it passing a bill to reopen the
government for three weeks it now heads
over to the house for a vote expected
tonight
president Trump announcing the deal to
end the 35 day partial government
shutdown the bill doesn't include wall
funding but the president vows to keep
fighting for it wall should not be
controversial that's why most of the
Democrats in Congress have voted in the
past four bills that include walls and
physical barriers and very powerful
fences if we don't get a fair deal from
Congress the government will either shut
down on February 15th again or I will
use the powers afforded to me under the
laws and the Constitution of the United
States to address this emergency Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer placing
the shutdown blame on president Trump
hopefully now the president has learned
his lesson we cannot cannot ever hold
American workers hostage again we helped
make it clear to the president to the
public that the president was the one in
charge of the shutdown and House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi saying once the government
is back open she's willing to work with
the President to set a date for the
State of the Union so Jesse we are back
to where we began before the shutdown
even started so now there's three weeks
to go yeah well thank God it's over
right now I think Trump lost the battle
so he's got to win the war he's got to
get something out of an emergency
declaration and if he doesn't get
something done there he has to flip the
house you think he will do a national
emergency yeah because I know I still
think they're too far apart so he's got
to do the national emergency it's got to
get reelected so then maybe he has more
of a mandate more political capital to
get the wall funding but at this point
the last shutdown was the Schumer
shutdown and that was perfectly teed up
for the president because Schumer was
protecting illegal immigrants over
veterans getting paid this dynamic was
totally different because the president
took ownership of the shutdown and then
it was the border wall funding versus
American federal workers
getting paid and that really wasn't a
very good dynamic for him and Pelosi
just obstructed to the media helped her
so she just waited him out it's five
weeks well later and people didn't get
paid and there's no border wall so where
do we stand I don't know it just seems
like the airplane situation the Calais
statement from the Commerce Secretary
the FBI director coming out and saying
reopen this thing that was what cranked
up the pressure in order for the
President to change gears so I think
sometimes leaders have to do that right
they have to say okay well this isn't
working we're gonna have to switch gears
what he said he lost the battle but the
war still going look okay this is
tiresome it's it's boring and it's
infuriating and it's frustrating because
this isn't just pure politics this is a
petulant reaction to a phenomenon right
walls are normal we have walls they've
be willing to spend more money than he's
actually asking for so it's not about
immigration at all it's about Trump and
Trump whether you like him or you hate
him he's the phenomenon of the last two
years that has created this kind of
animosity right these people I don't see
any compromise coming in this because if
the Dems compromise the media will will
just rip them to shreds this is a
personal vendetta against Trump they're
putting now they're putting security and
they're putting the government employees
up you know to the side in favor of
their own personal hatred of Trump
that's why I find it so boring and so
tiresome because I know this isn't going
to change we're gonna get at least we're
gonna get two more years possibly six
more years of this and ask you Dan
so we're back where we were before right
there's a president supporters not do
him any favors by pushing it pushing him
into fights that he can't possibly win
no because he can win this two points on
this first I thought Schumer handled
that awfully Nancy Pelosi clearly
understood she had a toe the middle on
that while giving that press conference
Schumer came off like a total snake you
know Trump gives a capitulates to some
of the Democrats demands and comes to
that it comes to the table opens up the
government and what is Schumer do he
comes out and twice repeats the point we
- have you learned the lesson what there
was no need for that I think the
pressure need to be a sort well no
president should pull that deal off the
table right now it's a good good luck
Chuck I'd knock it out on your own now
and the second point is listen politics
is all about a political bank account
right having PO I don't mean money I
mean building a political capital the
president now has three weeks to race to
the finish line to get a deal his base
can can really coalesce around you know
wasn't a great day today for the
president was ingredients he doesn't do
that and he does a national emergency
then you think the base of be fine with
I'm not a huge fan of the national
emergency plan I'm always afraid of
centralizing power and government in any
office even when it's a Republican
president I refuse to be a hypocrite on
that but having said that the Congress
did delegate him that power and it would
be legal to do it I don't agree with it
but it is there it's an option and his
base you know may may in fact like
something like that by the time he
builds a lot of that wall by the way and
it makes it through the courts he could
build a whole boatload of wall before it
even gets long and the election will
have been completed by then likely um
Murray the president even said in the
Rose Garden today we don't need two
thousand miles of a concrete wall I've
already said that like the Democrats
have already voted for barriers like so
really what are we fighting over at this
point well I think Donald Trump or at
least his political team saw what
happened in the Senate yesterday that
Mitch McConnell I think was very shrewd
in putting forward both bills and
showing demonstrating to the president
that his plan had fewer votes actually
than essentially what they ended up
passing today a CR to fight over this
for a few more weeks you know the
president yesterday at this time the
White House was saying we will do a CR
for three weeks with a very large down
payment well the president agreed to do
that with no down payment today so he I
think saw the political writing on the
wall that for the oval office address
and all of the way he's been messaging
this the numbers haven't really moved
and he's been getting blamed I actually
think that given the fact that Democrats
feel like they won this round they will
feel empowered to make possibly a
compromise so something like I said
yesterday let's say five billion that
includes barriers where experts say
they're needed in the president's day
talking about an expert sort of glue I
liked that too I think that's just like
some sort of commission I think that was
Greg's identity I stole that from Scott
Adams
that was a Scott Adams idea I stole may
feel empowered to say okay now we are
going to compromise on this if we get
daca if we get TPS I also think the
other lesson I took from this Nancy
Pelosi is someone it's Nancy Pelosi is
someone that I have underestimated as a
Democrat I wanted someone else to be
Speaker I underestimated her ability to
win the rollback and I underestimated
her ability to go toe to toe with Trump
and she showed him that things are
different in Washington now I know it's
gonna be like you know what because I
shrink totally non-sex it they're both
workhorses there are old workhorses
they're both similar in age right she's
been around he's been around
bamp but you it said what are they
fighting for you know what it is it's
like the ugly vase in a divorce
note when they were married when they
were married nobody wanted the base
right that's what the immigration is
nobody wants to talk about it you know
that's the a limit and then they get in
a fight and it's like they're fighting
over there they don't even like the base
but they're gonna fight over it even
though it's not a big deal but I do
think to the point that you brought up
about the panel of experts and engineers
as this objective group right his is a
step forward which means for the war it
could win he could win this using that
as to be one of the waters and this is
my wall